[Music]
I reject nation it's Greg Alba here John
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
predator the official trailer this movie
comes out in September before going into
this trailer reaction and review
hopefully this is better than the last
teaser trailer we gonna give a patron
the day shout out to none other than
Scuba Steve scuba Steve my good friend
this guy has an awesome Instagram page
with a lot of great graffiti artwork
he's also a huge horror movie nut this
guy it's my hope for you that someday
you get to cameo in a predator movie is
the person who dies like 10 minutes in
when he's caught tagging the side of one
of their ships or something like that
you know like as a mildly comic relief
add to the body count we should all be
so lucky
and Steve thanks for joining our patreon
page buddy you've been so kind in the
way you chitchat with us all the time I
don't think you watch any more of our
videos but I'm glad you're still a part
of the patreon page like most of our
patrons do you know what my job
description is badass I'm an
acquisitions
I look up and I catch what falls out of
the sky
catch this tell me about the mission did
you see anything unusual it's above our
vagary eyes
[Music]
not gonna come you now
look I get it something went down in
Mexico nobody wants any witnesses we
need to know if you can you mad pose a
threat
we're Rangers your mom's vagina we're
video game to be rated E for Everyone
[Music]
[Music]
making hats out of rib cages the
conquered space but that's not what's on
the horizon shiny worried right I think
you know what is on the ship the
ultimate predators we may die
we're still here
so come and get us [ __ ] nice so
that's right was better than the other
one it gives you more of a tone a better
build-up I guess a lot of bone crunching
and badassery it's it's really more just
an expansion the other one just like a
shorter version of this rail just the
other ones more breathing they don't
feel like I saw a whole lot new just no
no not a whole lot they do give insight
into sterling K Browns character I'm
like how do you know so much about these
guys I feel like he was the coolest
thing about this trailer for sure like
just his presence alone it seems like
his hotel Artemus performance yeah sure
is if you talking to Olivia Munn who's
the scientist lately confused by the
situation
it looks like certainly Kate Browns the
main character in the Amanda Waller of
this suicides I kind of get the
impression he is though because in the
first trailer he does that thing we
really saw something oh yeah seems like
he's just another cool soldier he might
actually know a lot more than what he's
leading on in the beginning of this film
I'm still kind of confused by what's
going on with the Predators are they
fighting each other exactly you know
yeah it looks like there's gonna be like
two breakouts at one time there's gonna
be the one predator who's in the lab who
puts on the mass and that's I like the
aesthetic when he puts on the mass and
the eye the blue lights come on that's
how I wake up every morning before I do
reactions the other one with the
crazy-looking predator was reaction
world I would be the one in the lab
Tyrone Magnus would be the other and get
a slightly better look at the cast of
characters you get Thomas Jane giving
the middle finger and strangling
keegan-michael key after you give
Michael key delivers a joke that kind of
sounds like he's trying to make his
voice sound lower than it is I'm
wondering is
gonna be the personality of the movie
because I feel like the cast of
characters here of these kind of crazy
soldiers are gonna bring a certain
personality to the film you got just the
darks it's a movie but then you then you
got these like kind of wacky psychotic
soldiers in here keegan-michael key is
line did it really fit in this trailer
and then his laughs after if your mom's
vagina were a video game to be rated E
for Everyone
it seems like there's a personality of
these soldiers that are gonna bring a
whole new layer to this film the trailer
is not doing anything to reflect that
none of the trailers that yeah I wonder
if at some point we're gonna get an ad
or a TV spot that's like about the team
or something because I always associate
one of the tropes of a predator movie is
you have the ensemble of you know badass
meatheads enough we're gonna go up
against the predator
it means predator carnage decided as
that was the last it's just from you
with all the hype they've done with
building this movie up and then it
coming back a shame black doing it your
expectations get a little bit higher on
what you wanted to sort of live up to
and be like the best predator since the
original oh you know I think that's the
element that's been missing for me from
these trailers each is like yeah there's
some cool images and stuff and I'm still
like interested in what the predator is
gonna be but I don't feel like I really
get the sense for like what Shane Black
is truly bringing to this for many of
these trailers yeah I can't put my
finger on one is do them seen the movie
but there's something that feels like
it's not quite being communicated to me
I think it's the characters because
Shane black specialty is in the unique
characters and the personalities of them
and they keep hitting at their
personalities but none of that's being
allowed to lead any of the trailers yeah
it's always from the same handful of
moments yeah see those characters anyway
I don't know you know none of the
writers oh isn't it great since the
Predators are I know this could be the
best predator movie since the original
predator I liked predators a couple
years ago yeah I liked it too that one's
cool my
you know I don't feel like that movie is
impossible to top though are you guys
excited for this or he's still a little
underwhelmed I know the general
consensus was pretty underwhelming for
the last time around but you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell you can check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A s music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron oject today